ich frage mich also bevor die These
eigentlich eine Frage und zwar was ist
eigentlich unsere Wunschvorstellung was
hätten wir gerne als Ausgang als das
Ideal was wir uns von unserer Politik
gegenüber den Krieg in der Ukraine
vorstellen und da sind für mich so zwei
Aspekte also ein menschlicher Aspekt und
der und der gopolitische Aspekt und der
menschliche Aspekt ist wenn man sich den
Krieg vorstellt dann ist das kein Krieg
zwischen zwei abstrakten Ukrainern den
Ukrainern und den Russen ja es ist ein
Krieg zwischen Menschen also wo Menschen
aufeinander schießen die sehr viel
gemeinsam miteinander haben die zum Teil
die gleiche Sprache sprechen die
vielleicht sogar verwandt sind
miteinander die ähnliches essen mögen
sage ich jetzt mal so pauschal und
vieles andere diese verbindet ja und
einen Krieg kann man vielleicht wenn man
in über einen Krieg nachdenkt als ein
Territorium dann kann man vielleicht mit
Waffen ein Territorium wieder frei
schießen aber man kann die Herzen von
Menschen nicht frei schießen und in
in diesem Sinne glaube ich nicht dass
man diesen Konflikt mit Waffen lösen
kann weil man wird mit Waffen irgendwas
lösen aber in diesen Herzen den Menschen
bleibt ohne Verlierer ohne Gewinner ohne
Gerechtigkeit ja und das ist eine Frage
die uns glaube ich uns stellen müssen
und dann wenn wir jetzt zu diesem
globalitischen zurückkommen also die der
zweite Aspekt um sozusagen dann frage
ich mich auch was ist unsere
Zielvorstellung also was ist um
sozusagen auch unser Horizont wenn wir
jetzt denken okay mit Waffengewalt
wollen wir an die Grenzen zurück von
2014 gut aber wir sind eigentlich diese
Grenzen von 2014 entstanden und das muss
ich jetzt alles nicht erzählen wenn wir
die letzten 100 Jahre zurückblicken der
zweite der Zweite Weltkrieg der Erste
Weltkrieg die Revolution die
Bürgerkriegs ähnlichen Zustände in den
20er Jahren all das und dann die Zeit
der Weltmächte in Anführungsstrichen die
dann praktisch über die Köpfe der
Menschen hinweg bestimmen wie die
Grenzen verlaufen das ist zwischen Polen
und so und nicht mehr so das ist
zwischen Ukraine und Russland so und so
weiter und so fort und ich frage mich
ist das der Horizont wo wir sagen das
wäre Gerechtigkeit wenn wir diesen
Zustand wiederherstellen ich glaube
nicht das ist nicht der Horizont den wir
suchen sollen weil sonst sind wir
ständig hinkriegen wir im Balkan wir
machen das einmal ganz konkret damit die
Zuschauer auch Folgen können sie fordern
eigentlich einen Waffenstillstand wenn
ich sie richtig verstehe und dass man
darauf hinarbeiten muss Kapitulation der
Ukraine das ist was anderes
ich habe doch ich würde hier auch eine
Frage stellen weil man muss natürlich
fragen wie ist dieser Waffenstillstand
zu erreichen hier würde ich einmal her
freuen Fragen konkret hieße das ja wenn
ich der Logik Folge und bitte
unterbringen wenn ich es nicht tue dass
man keine Waffen mehr liefern sollte an
die Ukraine es würde auch für Amerika
gelten würden sie da mitgehen
ich glaube alle jeder von uns will ein
Ende des Krieges jeder von uns will
keinen Morgen und kann sterben mehr ich
glaube das ist ja gut die Frage ist wo
kommen wir her wir haben
völkerrechtliche verträ hat Russland
hatte Souveränität der Grenzen der
Ukraine 1991/92 bestätigt das haben wir
alles und da gibt es jemanden im Kreml
der marschiert durch Europa der hat sich
erst Teile von Tschetschenien genommen
dann hat sich Teile von Georgien
genommen dann hat er sich Teile von
Ukraine genommen und schauen Sie die hat
innenpolitisch unglaubliche
Schwierigkeiten der Mann und der wird
gefeiert als fast als Held als die Krim
und nach Hause kam als Teile von von
Georgien nach Hause kam so wie es
bezeichnet und dieser Mann braucht
diesen diese Erfüllung diese
Befriedigung die die sucht er wie ein
Süchtiger weil er zu Hause nichts
vorweisen kann aber gar nichts er sagt
das ganz offen nämlich
Union nicht überwunden Diktatoren sind
ehrliche Leute
Führer hat auch alles in seinem Kampf
also keine Überraschung gewesen
und absolut durch Europa sieht sie mit
dem Stift zieht die Grenzen neu und er
hört er nicht auf es ist ein Irrglauben
zu denken wie einiges kriegt also Teile
ab wofür eigentlich kriegt Teile ab des
Landes dann ist er ja nicht zu Ende der
macht ja weiter er macht ja in Syrien
hat er weiter gemacht der hat so eine
Mörderpuppe diese wagnertruppe okay aber
ich meine wir haben sogar noch rum also
es ist ein Irrtum zu glauben man könnte
mit dem peacement hätte man damals Nazi
Deutschland Hitler stoppen können aber
wir haben wir haben ja keinen Einfluss
darauf und worauf die Einfluss haben ist
unsere Politik und auch unsere
Fragestellung und ich als Schriftsteller
versuch mich da auch irgendwie ein
bisschen um zu sagen tiefer zu gucken
und mich zu fragen okay welche Welt
wünsche ich mir eigentlich weil das ist
kein Krisenmanagement und ich äh das das
wäre natürlich
der Ukraine von 1991 ist der
gewährleistet worden und das und das hat
auch super aber dazwischen die in dieser
Grenze ja wo ich auch oft unterwegs war
erleben Leute die wie gesagt russisch
sprechen auf der einen oder auf der
anderen Seite oder bis vor kurzem haben
solche gelebt die leben Menschen die
ihre jemanden haben auf der einen und
auf der anderen Seite und dem allen
wollen wir irgendwie Rechnung tragen
auf Italiener und wunderbar gehören aber
da ist die Europäische Union und hier
und wir müssen uns fragen aber
lange in der Europäischen Union drin wir
haben Teile in Dänemark die sind auch
deutschsprachig wir haben Teile in
Ostbelgien die sind deutschsprachig wir
haben und trotzdem ist es nicht
Deutschland ich sag einfach mal ich gehe
aber kein Kriege ein bisschen
shoppen hol mal ein bisschen Krieg rüber
sie müssen den Mann einfach mitteilen es
ist hier zu Ende dein dein Elixier aus
dem du im politischen Kraft ziehst hat
aber dazu aber
nicht
und ich lasse heute sterbe ich die
größte Überreichung
nacheinander sonst hat dir keiner mehr
Spaß oder ich bin sehr viel Spaß das ist
schon okay ich finde nur wenn Sie fragen
welche Welt wir uns wünschen ich kann
das ganz klar sagen ich wünsche mir eine
Welt wo Schriftsteller aufhören über
Politik zu fantasieren das war ein
Fortschritt schon und sagen Sie mir ein
Beispiel war Schriftsteller studieren
durchaus Romanen wunderbaren gleich ein
galitären Gedanken die Welt verändert
haben haben sie was erreicht sie als
Schriftsteller ich meine klein
geschrieben haben die Leute was erreicht
die sich mit Hitler angefreundet haben
die Stalin zugejubelt haben die
Geschichte des Versagen
entgegen kommen
da gibt es vieles eines ich glaube wir
müssen uns auch ein bisschen in den
Debatten davon lösen dass wir mit
Feststellungen argumentieren ja dass wir
sagen sie machen eine Feststellung und
dann ist die Welt so
können Sie das
belegene Erfahrungen mit historisches
erfahrener bitte die sind evident welche
historischen Erfahrungen sind da kommen
1988 die ganze Politik den Nazis
gegenüber verstehen sie die Konferenz
von darum ging die deutschen Juden zu
retten also Konferenz Erfolges
auseinander ging wo ist der Hitler er
kann machen was er will wenn man dem
Bösen nicht von Anfang an talerat glaube
ich gesagt die nötigen Grausamkeiten
müssen am Anfang brauchen
unsere Referenz ist unter danke dass die
Talent auf jeden Fall das wäre nämlich
gewesen genau das ist nämlich der Punkt
unsere referenzhose und das 1815 und der
Wiener Kongress und eine Reaktion eines
reaktionärer Politik gegenüber der
französischen Revolution und dem alles
was danach war und das ist nämlich
glaube ich das Problem weil wir nämlich
seitdem innerhalb von Grenzen reden die
nichts gerecht ist haben für die
Menschen sind Grenzen sind immer
vielleicht schaffen
abschaffen aber vielleicht ein bisschen
locker lassen aber
Bruder
wenn man nach den Grenzen geht dann
müsste man sagen ist die Ukraine nicht
mit drinnen in unserem Bündnis wenn man
Grenzen nimmt
nicht in der NATO
eingelassen was in Deutschland keinen
guten Ruf hat die leisten Widerstand
wenn wir über Grenzen reden entsteht
keiner nicht mit drin es gab Verträge es
gab Abkommen es gab Regelungen unter
anderem hat die Ukraine
leichtsinnigerweise wäre Atomwaffen
verzichtet statt sich so viele zu
benehmen wie Nordkorea es macht mit
Atomwaffen wäre wahrscheinlich dieser
russische Einfall nicht passiert aber
diese Verträge konservieren ja praktisch
das was wir seit 200 Jahren in Europa
haben wollen die Europa nur Europa neu
ziehen ich sage nicht wieder haben was
sagen sie dazu ich will nicht ich sage
nicht was ich will in Europa machen ich
möchte eine Debatte starten darüber die
einfach sich in Klaren ist dass wir hier
mit Umständen zu tun haben mit vertagten
Entscheidungen vertagt und Debatten mit
Ergebnissen von machtpolitischen
Entscheidungen
ich weiß gar nicht ob sie was dazu sagen
sollten entscheidet ja wer Experte ist
bei dem Thema grundsätzlich
ich will vielleicht
ich höre viele Dinge ich habe in der
Geschichte auch aufgepasst und wenn wir
hier schon darüber reden was damals und
was heute sich ähnelt wenn wir von
Diktatoren sprechen
möchte ich alle hier im Raum und da
draußen an eines erinnern an etwas ganz
Wichtiges
wenn wir ihn schon mit Hitler
vergleichen ja
dieser Mann
schießt nicht mit Gewehren dieser Mann
besitzt
6.600
Atomwaffen
6600 Atomwaffen und wenn dieser Mann
seine Macht verliert weist er dass sein
Leben vorbei ist also bitte ich alle
dieses Spielchen auf einem Schachbrett
was wir hier spielen genau zu überdenken
ich weiß nicht auf wen von ihnen schon
geschossen wurde auf mich ist geschossen
worden
nee mit Atomwaffen nicht da war eine
Waffe schon ausreichend aber schießen
tut man bei Atomwaffen nicht man drückt
nur auf den Knopf und diese Macht hat
dieser Mann und ich bitte das ist den
Philosophie der Kapitulation
kapitulieren soll hier keiner ich will
nur daran erinnern dass wir 6600 Waffen
da auf der anderen Seite verstanden
mit einer Atomwaffe halb Europa
auslöschen das wird nicht Europa treffen
wenn er sich ein Ziel aussucht dann wird
das Ziel
haben sie einen direkten Draht zu
Pudding ich habe nur einen direkten
Draht zu Gerhard Schröder das ist schon
schlimm genug
sie Fantasien etwas herbei bei ich habe
etwas vor etwas Angst was real ist aber
mit der Angst müssen sie allein fertig
werden ich habe andere Ängste ich habe
die Angst es wird keine Beute der Kekse
mehr geben das wäre für mich das
Schlimmste na ja es ist entschuldige das
ist vollkommen albern seien sie mir
nicht böse ich verehre sie ja aber das
ist völliger Unsinn mit dieser
Argumentation kann jeder Diktator alles
unternehmen alles vernichten Bruder
haben Sie denn sind sie besorgt um
Atomwaffen ja natürlich
aber dann heißt also
wir müssen dann überhaupt nicht warten
bis Putin einen Schritt weitergeht wir
können gleich sagen was 6000 €
Atomwaffen wir geben die gleich Estland
Lettland Dieter und tollen Tschechien
Slowakei Ungarn Rumänien Bulgarien die
Moldau ja und vielleicht noch ein Stück
von Griechenland weil es auch mal eine
russische Migration gegeben hat ich
wollte auch einen Punkt zurückkommen ich
wiederhole mich ungern aber diesmal muss
ich es machen ich habe das schon mal
gesagt
putin ist Hitler und nach Holocaust und
das ist nicht unangemessen sagen Sie
jetzt nicht dass das einmalig war das
war einmalig aber abgesehen davon dass
er keine Massenvernichtung mit
industriellen Mitten betreibt macht er
die grau die gleiche Taktik und
Strategie verbrannte Erde Massenmord
Nötigung Entführung die reine Gewalt und
wenn er somit ist wie er wie sie ihn
beschreiben was hält ihn davon ab in den
letzten Schritt zu machen genau wie
Hitler den totalen
will warum wissen sie der Mann hat so
viele immobilieninvestieren warum soll
sich umbringen da kann auf seine Jagd
gehen die gerade den kann vor allem das
ist wenn die Gerüchte stimmen dass er
krank ist
spekulationsniveau gerade
das ist ganz einfach
wenn ich der erste Diktator dabei
also ich finde es schön dass wir alles
so schön blumig malen ich hoffe dass es
so ist und dass wir dass es nie dazu
kommt denn wenn es dazu kommt kann ich
was sagen haben sie sie können ihm geben
was sie wollen ich finde ihn gar nichts
geben ich will das Menschlichkeit
auf dieser Welt herrscht und nicht nur
nicht in der Ukraine sondern sonst
überall wunderbar dann fahren wir doch
bei jedem an wo kann sein furchtbar
stattfinden
nicht pro Millionen von Menschen
verreckt sind aber seit weit weg das ist
das entscheidende warum wir darüber
wahrscheinlich nicht so reden gar nicht
mit einem Druck auf einer Taste sind sie
heute mit jedem nicht interessiert und
sagt Interessiert und Insel hat die
krimlich interessiert letzter
Konsequenzen nur weil es jetzt auf
breiter Front geschickt wir haben zwei
Vertrag wurde nach der Annexion der
kriminiert
das war die Sanktion Helmut Schmidt hat
sogar angefangen seit 80 Jahren des
Mannes Röhren Deal zu unterschreiben da
gehen die ganze Elend ja los mit der
russischen Gas Abhängigkeit das hat ja
dein fortgesetzt also das ist ja kein
Prozess der letzte Bundesregierung
eigentlich geringste unserer inspirieren
zum unterwerfen genau
gegenüber solchen Leuten die Putin
auftreten wenn er entschlossen ist zum
Untergang dann wird er auch dann dieses
diesen Entschluss durchsetzen wenn wir
ihn vorher wissen die Churchill hat
gesagt ist eine Pizza ist jemand dein
Krokodil füttert in der Hoffnung es
werde das letzten Essen und genau das
ist jetzt unsere Situation und da gibt
es halt nicht so beschönigen und noch
mal zu den Grenzen natürlich sind alle
Grenzen willkürlich in Europa sind sie
weitgehend aufgehoben also wir haben
viele Verfassung wir haben ja den Rücken
Status des Verfassungsstaates wenn man
Beispiel also durch Frankreich natürlich
sehr homogen und Staatsgebilde so von
der Form her dann gibt es natürlich die
Schweiz zum Beispiel ist ein klassischer
Verfassungsstaat da gibt es also Tessin
da gibt's die Franzose und bis heute ist
das ja sind die auch politisch da sehr
sehr gespalten wir haben es eine Ukraine
da haben sie vollkommen Recht da haben
wir natürlich Minderheiten und so weiter
und so fort viele Grenzen es ist ein
Land zu überfallen starten und keine
organische einmal unterbrechen ich
glaube da sind wir vereinig am Tisch das
niemand sagt dass der Angriffskrieg in
irgendeiner Form legitimiert ist da ist
auf dieser Welt ist nicht legitim egal
welcher nicht nur hier egal